this is a production of Cornell
University
we are late for lunch so I will make
this brief but hopefully challenging is
well New York Farm Bureau's and advocacy
organization spent a lot of time here at
the Capitol lobbying legislators in
staff on a whole host of agricultural
issues including soil health a lot of
people we actually lobby here so I want
to thank the people from the Senate the
assembly staff for being here in this
much it's real real testament to their
dedication so thank you how many people
here are from South of West Chester
County
that's good welcome but that's not
enough we have this whole soil health
equals farm profitability equation
nailed to the greatest extent I will
almost a great extent we have a lot of
legislative partners from upstate New
York who help with incentives the pass
incentives legislation for soil carbon
sequestration we have people from taking
your championing Environmental
Protection Fund in AEM program
Nonpoint program I don't lose a
Brazilian farming but that's not enough
there's 20 million people in New York
State this is us we are the 40 percent
upstate people with representation
there's a whole other 60 percent Long
Island in the five boroughs in Manhattan
who don't really honestly care about
soil health but we are in the sweet spot
though there's always a lot of to borrow
a phrase from one of the earlier sides
slides a lot of cussing and fussing
about agriculture here in Albany and
even within our industry whether it's
GMO versus conventional whether it's
pesticide use labor issues big versus
small this issue is not one of those
custom custom issues because we can tell
the story to farm allegedly of districts
about farm profitability that comes from
soil health but even more importantly we
can start talking to urban legislators
about climate change in the mitigation
impacts that soil health has they care
about much more frankly about climate
change in place will health and our
mission our goal is to tell that story
this has been a lot of farmer-to-farmer
stuff and that's really needed because
we need to extend this knowledge base
across the state but we can't ignore the
work that's done here because this
conference wouldn't have happened
without state funding
Dave's programs the research wouldn't
happen without state funding EPF funding
for AEM
Patrick hooker talking about extending
technical knowledge in technical advice
on soil health and the AEM program
wouldn't happen without state support
funding in legislation and so I guess my
challenge and the short time I have
today is to say let this not be the only
time that you come to Albany to talk
about soil health we need to continue
this drumbeat the well legislative
session throughout the year with
legislators and staff because there's so
many issues out there that are outside
of Agriculture that they are hit with
every single day this needs to be one of
those issues as well or else oh forget
about it and this issue is far far too
important far far far too many powerful
legs to have that happen so that's the
challenge and mouse time for lunch thank
you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu